With all the sequels, reboots, spin-offs,
and occasional original films that get released
every month, it can be hard to keep track
of what's actually getting released.
Luckily, we've combed through every notable
movie release that's coming down the pipeline
this Fall so you won't have to worry about
missing anything.
Here are some of the future blockbusters we're
projecting will hit it big in the Fall, in
order of their expected release date.
Mandy
It seems like Nicolas Cage's entire career
was leading to Mandy.
The story follows a mountain man named Red
whose girlfriend, Mandy, is kidnapped, leading
him to embark on a brutal odyssey of revenge
against the cult leader responsible.
Pretty much everyone who's seen Mandy has
walked away praising both Cage's performance
and director Panos Cosmatos' dedication to
making a truly insane film.
The movie drops into theaters September 14th,
so keep your schedule clear if you want to
see Nicholas Cage act insane in a way only
he can.
The Predator
Kicking off a new round of interplanetary
big game hunting, The Predator finds writer-director
Shane Black making a long-overdue return to
the franchise.
According to actor Thomas Jane, the plot will
involve a group of PTSD-stricken soldiers
who band together to kill the spine-cracking
alien hunters.
The movie's got an incredible cast, featuring
Olivia Munn, Trevante Rhodes, Keegan-Michael
Key, Sterling K. Brown, and Edward James Olmos.
We can expect our ragtag heroes to face off
against everyone's favorite skull collector
on September 14th.
Operation Finale
Directed by Chris Weitz, Operation Finale
tells the true story of an elite Israeli spy
unit tasked with capturing a high-profile
Nazi who escaped to Argentina after the war.
With Oscar Isaac starring as the leader of
the unit and Ben Kingsley as the fugitive
nazi, there's sure to be some incredible acting
in this historical drama.
The film hits theaters on September 14th,
and if you're at all interested in history,
espionage, or real-life revenge stories, then
Operation Finale might be right up your alley.
The House with a Clock in its Walls
Eli Roth isn't really known for his kid-friendly
films, but he's looking to change things up
with The House with a Clock in its Walls.
Based on the classic children's book by John
Bellairs, this Gothic fright flick tells the
story of a 10-year-old boy who's sent to live
in a quiet Michigan town with an uncle, played
by Jack Black, who turns out to be a warlock.
The House with a Clock in its Walls also stars
Cate Blanchett and Kyle Maclachlan, and it's
set to scare kids on September 21st.
The Old Man and the Gun
While his films don't usually get a lot of
attention from mainstream audiences, director
David Lowery has been on a low-key roll since
2013, with movies like Ain't Them Bodies Saints,
Pete's Dragon, and A Ghost Story.
Now, Lowery is re-teaming with Robert Redford
for The Old Man and the Gun, the amazing true
story of Forrest Tucker, a 71-year-old crook
who escaped from prison and went on a bank
robbing spree around the country.
Sissy Spacek plays his love interest, and
Casey Affleck stars as the cop determined
to bring him down.
The Old Man and the Gun will arrive on September
28th, which gives you plenty of time to visit
your own elderly relatives and hear about
their wild lives first.
Venom
Everyone's favorite spider-themed anti-hero,
Venom, is finally going to star in a major
motion picture.
The alien symbiote is now slated to sling
his way into theaters on October 5th, 2018,
with Tom Hardy in the title role.
Hardy's not the only acting powerhouse to
appear in the film; Venom also stars Riz Ahmed,
Michelle Williams, and Jenny Slate.
With this much talent involved, Venom is at
least guaranteed to be more watchable than
the last time he appeared on screen.
Bad Times at the El Royale
Sometimes all a movie needs to do is pack
in enough talented actors for it to be incredible,
and Bad Times at the El Royale definitely
looks like a sleazy good time with some talented
actors.
Jeff Bridges, Chris Hemsworth, Dakota Johnson,
and Jon Hamm star in the noir-ish movie written
and directed by Drew Goddard, best known for
helming Cabin in the Woods.
While plot details are scarce, we know the
story is set in the '60s and involves a bunch
of crooks who wind up at a Lake Tahoe hotel.
There's a bank robbery, a cult leader, and
a mysterious organization spying on the hotel
guests.
Regardless, we're pretty excited to watch
these unsavory characters go head-to-head
on October 5th.
First Man
After the smashing success of La La Land,
Ryan Gosling and Damien Chazelle will be joining
forces again for First Man.
Instead of singing "City of Stars," Gosling
will be shooting for the moon.
First Man will tell the story of the Space
Race, with Gosling playing Neil Armstrong,
the first man to walk on the moon in 1969.
Along with Gosling, Corey Stoll plays astronaut
Buzz Aldrin, Lukas Haas plays astronaut Mike
Collins, and the cast will be rounded out
by Kyle Chandler, Claire Foy, Pablo Schreiber,
and Jon Bernthal.
The film is in incredibly capable hands, so
we can't wait for First Man to finally launch
on October 12th.
T-minus several months and counting…
Serenity
Written and directed by Steven Knight, Serenity
promises to be anything but serene.
The film follows a fishing boat captain played
by Matthew McConaughey who gets lured into
a murderous scheme by a femme fatale, played
by Anne Hathaway.
She's sick and tired of being abused by her
wealthy husband, so she wants McConaughey
to turn the guy into shark food.
Of course, in film noir, nothing is ever as
it seems, and you can't trust anyone … even
Anne Hathaway.
Serenity sails into theaters on October 19,
and judging by the trailer, this shark-infested
thriller promises to have quite a bite.
"You're gonna need a bigger boat."
The Sisters Brothers
Based on the acclaimed novel by Patrick deWitt,
the story follows a pair of brothers whose
last name is Sisters.
The Sisters brothers make their living killing
people, and they're sent to hunt down a chemist
who's stolen a formula that reveals the location
of gold.
The gunslinging siblings are played by Joaquin
Phoenix and John C. Reilly, Riz Ahmed plays
their prey, and Jake Gyllenhaal stars as a
miner caught in the middle.
Plus, there's Rutger Hauer and Carol Kane
rounding out the star-studded cast.
The Sisters Brothers promises to ride into
theaters this fall, and we can't wait to see
these actors fight it out in the Old West.
"Have you ever had to be in a fight?
I've been in a ton of fights.
That's why I figured out how to stay the heck
out of a fight."
The Nutcracker and the Four Realms
Disney is releasing their next live-action
fantasy just in time for Thanksgiving.
The Nutcracker and the Four Realms is set
to dance into cinemas on November 2nd, complete
with gorgeous sets, elaborate costumes, and
quite a few familiar faces.
Inspired by E.T.A. Hoffman's story, the plot
follows a young girl named Clara who winds
up in a strange world of talking nutcrackers,
intimidating toy soldiers, and scary rodents.
Along the way, she'll encounter a sugar plum
fairy that looks like Keira Knightley, a mysterious
old man who resembles Morgan Freeman, and
a villainous dictator who shares a certain
similarity to Helen Mirren.
Based on the trailers, we can expect the adaptation
of this beloved legend to dance in a dark
direction.
Bohemian Rhapsody
With his flawless voice and sexy swagger,
Freddie Mercury is one of the greatest rock
stars in music history.
A bio-pic has been in the works since 2010,
but the film hit multiple roadblocks along
the way.
Finally, Bohemian Rhapsody is set for a 2018
release date, with Rami Malek of Mr. Robot
playing the Queen frontman.
In addition to Malek's own voice, the film
will capture Mercury's unique vocal range
with the help of singer Marc Martel and sound
bites from Mercury himself.
It's taken eight long years for Bohemian Rhapsody
to get here, and when the film hits theaters
on November 2nd, it promises it will rock
you.
Robin Hood
Taron Egerton stars as Robin Hood, finally
bringing the outlaw archer back to the silver
screen for the first time in almost a decade.
However, this version won't be quite as merry
as the ones we've seen before.
"Lend me your ears!"
"...that's disgusting."
2018's Robin Hood is going to be like a medieval
version of Batman Begins, showing us how Robin
of Locksley became Great Britain's most famous
bandit.
Taking Robin Hood in a dark direction is certainly
an interesting choice, and with the winning
combo of Egerton and Jamie Foxx as his partner,
the upcoming action flick could be one of
2018's most exciting movies.
Robin Hood will be stealing its way into theaters
on November 21st.
Rich Moore and Phil Johnston, who wrote the
original script for Wreck-It Ralph, will share
directing duties, so it's bound to be a faithful
follow up to the original.
You'll get a chance to see if Wreck-It Ralph
2 is even better than the first one when it
arrives on November 21st.
Welcome to Marwen
Inspired by the 2010 documentary Marwencol,
director Robert Zemeckis will tell the story
of Mark Hogencamp, a crossdresser who was
brutally assaulted by a group of thugs.
Suffering from brain damage and PTSD, he coped
with his attack by constructing a miniature
World War II village in his backyard.
Welcome to Marwen stars Steve Carell in the
lead role, Gwendoline Christie as Hogencamp's
caretaker and Diane Kruger as a Belgian witch,
one of Hogencamp's characters come to life.
The film also features Leslie Mann and Janelle
Monae, and it's scheduled to arrive in theaters
on November 21st.